bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono pari j
oggi iniziamo un nuovo display the witch
house raga questo rpg che dovrebbe
sostituire il made father me l'avete
consigliati in tantissimi ho visto
qualche gameplay e sembra ancora
migliore di mezzo fa ho visto un paio di
cose già più colpi di scena ancora non
mi sono spiegato nulla tranquilli e
direi che possiamo iniziare a robbie
keane non avrei presente che cosa
sinceramente mi avete detto che un po di
tutto ci fa un po ridere è un po horror
c'è un po di tutto va beh allora siamo
in mezzo alla foresta perfetto ci sono
anche i pokémon c'è un gatto già
partiamo male c'è il gatto sul tronco a
sinistra beh ma posso già muovermi che
figo c'è niente presentazione bene
allora questo tipo i giochi horror che
non si sa come cazzo ci siamo finiti qui
va bene tenendo la capisce un gatto non
che cos'è scegli dove salva a questo
questo tipo ricordo di mezzi faccia in
ben fatta c'era il corvo qua c'è il
gatto va bene allora si corre con shift
fantastico bene non sapere che cosa devo
fare qua ci sono dei fiori che bloccano
il passaggio benissimo e non so non so
dove devo andare allora la casa e di
sopra e sotto e fuori dalla foresta io
andrei fuori dalla foresta sinceramente
infatti è più bloccato qui che soffrano
la cia faccio cos'è quella roba che
luccica c'è qualcosa da giura che la
vedo l'ho vista ho trovato qualcosa di
affilato e arrugginito cos'è prenderlo
non prendono io lo prendo ma non machete
un gadget ammazzare il gatto come si fa
la prima così infatti viola mi chiamo
viola c'è video cos'è allora c'è una
lettera c'è una lettera leggi cos'è
questa lettera
devi andare nella sua casa ma devi stare
lontano dalla foresta
spero di vederti presto papà ma lettera
che non sapevo di avere fantastico a
roma c'è the o un machete non ho capito
bene che cosa ha tipo ho capito mi serve
per tagliare sta roba
ok allora vinse funziona ma c'era italia
se funziona
non posso creare unica vettura perché
allora è troppo profonda si vede che
devo andare di sopra laga e poi è
sparito il gatto è sparito
non c'è più il gatto fantastico sarà
andata in casa e vabbè allora di
riaprire sta cosa questa ce la fai la
prima sono due fiori che poi i ragazzi
non capisco perché ma non riesce a
oltrepassare i due fiori c'è come fa il
machete si è rotto
sbagliato due fiori ma come fare va bè
ragazzi non facciamo domandano avanti
c'è ragazzi quali sopra ci dovrebbe
essere la casa cioè col gatto fantastico
è cos'è un gatto che parla perché sto
parlando
cos'è questo non lo so io che cos'è lo
stai facendo così la strada è bloccata
dalle le rose ma per ragazzi aperta la
porta da sola
vuoi entrare no non voglio entrare
entrato cos'è ma perché c'è un gatto
parlante così magari all'interno non
potrebbe uscire no ma fantastico e non
voglio entrare però devo farlo perché me
lo dice una lettera giustamente
sentimento non mi segui facciamo tipo tu
fai il gatto con gli stivali con la
spada novero non facciamo così ragazzi e
fantastico l'ambientazione epica non
voglio entrare qui dentro ma devo farlo
perché sia aperta una porta e c'è
qualcosa a terra spero non sia sangue ok
oddio cosa cazzo è successo ma non
abbiano sembra che partiti e già e
splatter cos'è sta roba
allora che a farsi salvare prima di
entrare e stavolta sono finisco
malissimo alla ragazzi dovrebbe
spiegarmi perché c'è una roba che
schiaccia la gente in una casa
cioè io non volevo neanche tra joe e
analizzare come faccio se non devo
camminare sul rosso penso credo
ok ho preso è fatta blend in via stanza
no non ci vengono abbastanza cos'è dove
dobbiamo andare i coach yamaha sono tipo
porte attraversabili no come faccio
cosa devo fare qui devo tornare indietro
cosa devo fare qui
ok è sparita la porta ed entrato il
gatto mi spieghi cosa è successo io ti
offro come sei un gatto rapper ho deciso
di servire di seguirti per le tue risate
risate
sì perché io rido mi schiacciano le
pareti e io rido comunque sia da dove
diavolo si saltata fuori allora lo
vorrei scoprire anche io sinceramente
perché non lo so
vabbè andiamo avanti abbiamo salvato
così se ci schiaccia qualcosa non
finiamo male cos'è sta roba
e c'è un paio di forbici sulla sua
scrivania premier se prendi tutto ciò
che ci serve
sono incatenate alla scrivania come sono
incatenati chiede il catena un paio di
forbici alla scrivania va bene la porta
è chiusa perfetto ci sono delle forbici
incatenate ragazzi perché ci sono delle
forbici in catene che incatena le
forbici
vabbè c'è un vaso di fiori o che sono
ancora machete nove sono stati otto
ragazzi c'è uno stacchiotti il cestino
un grande orsacchiotto suo interno e c'è
un qualcosa nella stanza sinistra si la
sto vedendo orso nel cestino grande è un
nuovo mica capito sai che c'era uno
strano cesino va bene e cosa cosa devo
fare niente orsoni ragazzi orso nel
cestino vi è tutto più chiaro adesso sì
anche a me che mi ha aperto un mondo sta
cosa veramente allora andiamo di sopra
c'è un pendolo c'è un time markson si
può dire che il tempo sta andando avanti
almeno non a rotoli fa piacere se non
batto di regali ce n'è uno per me dove
68 rimane a guardare le le pile di
regali premi l'orsacchiotto preso lo sa
che 8 perfetto ho preso un orsacchiotto
a caso c'è il diario della strega as i
ragazzi che poi tratto il titolo non ve
l'ho detto ma mi pare fosse ovvio che un
che the witch house dire la casa della
strega
quindi dovremmo essere nella casa di una
strega va bene stavo male nessuno voleva
giocare con me mio padre mia madre mio
padre mia madre non mi amavano
sì questa è una storia peggio di mezzo a
tutto qui fantastico un diario profondo
e vabbè ragazzo con controllato un
orsacchiotto che penso io devo ammettere
qui insieme all'altro perché c'è scritto
orsacchiotti nel cestino allora metti
nel cestino vailati sono troppo grandi
per entrare
e che cosa vuoi da me che colpa mia
mettilo ragade vasco che faccia
ok ho capito ho capito sono un genio
devo ammetterlo nelle forbici però prima
fatemi salvare che ho paura che comunque
le forbici ci finisco malissimo
va bene proviamoci lo stesso vai taglia
taglia ossa chiotto credo si debba fare
così allora rai agli arti
dell'orsacchiotto vai una cosa molto
macabra ma tanto non sa chi 8v se ne
fotte ho tagliato gli altri e non so che
8 perfetto ho preso il terzo
dell'orsacchiotto bene
raga cosa che chi chi è che ha lasciato
norma sul bura è perché c'è del sangue
perché c'è del sangue sulla forbice cene
sangue sulla forti non è il vasto c'è
anche un capitan ovvio dice cosa che già
so lo vedo che c'è il sangue su perché
c'è sangue sulla forbice da quando gli
acciaccati sanguinano perché si sono
svolte le luci perché sto giocando a
questo gioco
vabbè alle candele si sono spente a caso
sentito che mi fa degli scherzi vero
dimmelo
va bene il gatto che mi trova la sono
sicuro vabbè allora mettiamo
l'orsacchiotto guida ancora dovremo
farcela se bene ho inserito lo sa kyoto
nel cestino beh allora adesso ci siamo
ho sentito qualcosa sbloccarsi da
qualche parte bene allora dovrei aver
sbloccato qualcosa tipo una porta penso
sia questo perché ok non si apre bene
non sbloccato un cazzo
a noi la porta quella che ha coperto la
fa
[Musica]
raga che cazzo succede permesso c'è un
orma ragazzo vabbè io altra cosa non
l'ho capita comincia bene ok paranormal
vaso maledizione di melo che sta
complottando contro di me anche il vaso
il vaso è caduto ragazzi questo gioco mi
apre un mondo quando ok oggi cos'era
cosa era un orsacchiotto enorme
raga sono riusciti a scappare in un modo
assurdo e ho premuto destra c'era che
c'era un orsacchiotto ragazzi c'era un
orsacchiotto c'è anzi era un
orsacchiotto né non un orsacchiotto
e va bene ci è permesso c'erano ecco
penso siano sue le orme cosa era quella
roma che cos'è cos'è accaduto cos'è sta
roba ci sono ci sono le braccia del
nostro a kyoto a terra prendi le
prendiamo le braccia dell'orsacchiotto
che sono piene di sangue giustamente
dovrei aver sbloccato la porta si
infatti ce l'ho fatta ragazzi stiamo
addentrando sempre di più in questa casa
fantastica e non vedo l'ora veramente di
scoprire chi capsule sosa che offre
norme che mi ha appena cos'è un camino
si lo vedo guarda dentro ma diamo dentro
il camino non c'è nulla a parte la
fuliggine va bene mi fa piacere c'è del
ketchup qui sopra spero sia chi è ciap
dove c'è cos'è questo un teschio bello
bel piatto fantasma si possono spostare
risveglia e rimedia voglia c'è luce
della del liquido in un teschio e noi
beviamo cece baby baby ha voglia
ti dà la botta vero altro che vodka
viola è stata avvelenata un rubare di
qualcosa che si è sbloccato s'è sentito
da qualche parte
però mi sono avvelenati o cazzo ragazzo
sono avvelenata merda ma sono morta ho
capito che potevo più bere quella roba
lì qualsiasi cosa sia va beh voi
promemoria non bevete mai dai teschi se
vedete dei teschi non bevende la cucina
è occupata dai una mano una mano io c'ho
gli arti dell'orsacchiotto non so se
vanno bene uguale comunque qua c'è
qualcosa
raga io non ci sto capendo più niente
cosa sta succedendo la facciamo così
andiamo avanti
cosa c'è qui ok c'è uno scarafaggio
c'era una scarpa ge norme fermi che di
pesto chi festo tutti e cioè ragazzo un
coltello che si sta muovendo da solo c'è
qualcosa di visibile qui c'è qualcuno
che sta tagliando qualcosa di invisibile
parla a sono occupato sono occupato dai
una mano si allora lo attendiamo una
mano all uomo invisibile o grazie la
persona invisibile afferrato braccio lo
mette sul tagliere o cazzo
no aspettate un attimo fermi la mano
esattamente quello di cui ho bisogno
oh cazzo ma cosa raio ma che cazzo di
gioco ora c'è ma la roba è una roba
troppo splatter cazzo raga forse ho
capito cosa devo fare aspettate un
attimo
allora questo tipo qui a sto stronzo qui
servono delle braccia io gli darei quest
e guido le braccia a grazie avevo
bisogno di una mano al 2 va bè prendi
tre volentieri quelle non ci sono
problemi fammi vedere classe che tiri
mostri il mio apprezzamento va bene però
stai ferma grazie mi date una chiave
molto gentile e va bene finché usa le
braccia degli altri va bene allora ho
trovato una chiave devo usare la cosa
può perfetto ragazzi già facciamo
no la chiave non entra del tutto o cazzo
è un'equazione gli scarafaggi e era
pieno era pieno di scarafaggi fantastico
allora adesso dovrebbe entrare che
schifo non entrava perché sono gli
scarafaggi va bene eh no non entra
ancora veramente cazzo ma ce la fai
è una chiave deve usarla
voglio per resto roba maledizione cosa
devo fare mettici la lettera marito non
leggerete vaffanc la chiave caprio si
apre la lega si apre una tazza cioè mi
sembra giusto anzi un cranio spingilo
con la chiave oppure metti la chiave
nella zuppa no spingilo che la chiave si
è sentito un suono bene allora non era
quello la mettilo nel dentro la ce l'ho
fatta ho messo la chiave dovrebbe
succedere adesso la chiave è diventata
nera perfetto ma adesso devo prendere
s'è sentito il rumore di qualcosa che si
è sbloccato bene o cazzo si è sbloccato
paga l'avete vista c'era qualcosa dentro
dentro il camino guarda dentro la capo
abbiamo dentro camino cosa dovrebbe
esserci niente altra nella fuliggine
meno da che cosa cazzo mi è servito
spiegatemelo paranormal the job
no vabbè ragazze non è normale la
bottiglia è caduta grazie mille non
l'avevo notato adesso si è sbloccata di
capo cos'è ragano sono andato perché se
n'è andato ma riservarmi scala pagine o
per star lì tutte forse si aperta da
porsi la porta si aperta vai
probabilmente tratto qui dentro ma
entriamoci buongiorno vi casa dov'è che
è successo cosa verrà fuori l'oscurità
fuori è talmente tanta che l'occhio non
riesce a vedere perfetto
devo andare il ragazzo a qualcuno qui
sopra cela qualcosa ancora il gatto un
gatto decorativo di ornamento fantastico
ghiaccio
salviamo il gatto vista simpatie più del
corvo veramente parla molto di più del
corvo un cavaliere con la lancia
sembra che possa muoversi in qualsiasi
momento e speriamo che non si muova
un vaso di rose va bene quello abbiamo
capito ci sono classi ronnie porte
ragazze qualcosa salva la farfalla
salviamo le farfalle allora speriamo che
la farfalla non fosse tra quelli
scarafaggi perché in tal caso ho fallito
di brutto nelle pagine leggiamo le
pagine la corda in un barile
cosa vuol dire l'accordo c'è una corda
in un barile perfetto la cosa non l'ho
capita la voce una libreria qui unali
una piccola libreria c'e un libro che
manca perfetto io non ce l'ho qualsiasi
cosa sia non ce l'ho vorrei chiesti
hanno soltanto di pesto cece della roba
che ci sono ragazzi e più di roma che
luccica
c'è un libro intitolato the witch house
2 e penso che io devo andare in ordine a
leggerli perché se non va bene devo
trovare un libraio penso ci sia il tipo
invisibile non ne sono sicuro c'è
qualcuno in visibile qui lo vedo
dall'ombra e parla parla però non incida
equilibri e stai calmo stai calmo se
qualcosa in questi libri che non va
queste demolirli insieme si va bene stai
tranquillo però è stai molto tranquillo
oh cazzo rega c'è del sangue
non ho capito a questa pazza di sicura
che sta per succedere qualcosa di brutto
fatevi salvare vabbè ragazza temi sapere
se la serie vi piacerà che sinceramente
a me sta piacendo molto di più di mezz
vader promette benissimo dall'inizio
quindi vedremo comunque ragazzi come al
solito se il video è piaciuto al 7 un
momento mi piace anche alla pagina di
facebook e come non divido tratte nella
descrizione se la seta per i seed
iscrivetevi non ci vediamo al prossimo
video bei ragazzi